bonsoir ouais merci d'être là jean luc
lemoine pour les questions qui attire ça
nous a manqué un pendant quinze jours
jean-luc à celle ci s'étant que je sais
pas si ça vous a manqué ah oui si vous
savez pas ce qui va passer à l'est tout
juste une question bonjour je m'appelle
il dit je trouve cyril hanouna très
brillant et très beau au niveau du
physique donc je voulais savoir si les
chroniqueurs l'aimait vraiment ou s'il
faisait juste semblant pour rester dans
l'équipe
déjà la question est pas mal elle est
pas mal
c'est une très bonne question que vous
posez la chaire ai dit tu sais les
réponses qu'ils vont être durs je ne
sais pas y at il des fauves dans
l'équipe des des gens qui sera
uniquement par intérêt des gens qui
jalouseraient secrètement cyril il
n'attendrait que le bon moment pour lui
planter une pelle à gâteau dans le dos
évidemment non vous avez raison cyril
est très bon au niveau du physique du
visage et du corps
c'est pour ça qu'il plaît tant à tout le
monde aux filles et ça dans l'équipe
tout le monde le comprend
mais ce que j'aime c'est toujours de
vraies analyses mondiale les femmes
adorent les deux hommes qui réussissent
et sinon ils seraient trika comme nous
le poilu alors ça peut paraître
anecdotique comme magnéto mais le
problème c'est que c'est un sujet qui
travaille vraiment thierry moreau
paraissent que tous les jours la même
question revient non c'est pas vrai
c'est lui
mutilé
qu'est ce que les prix y trouva civile
j'attends
visiblement à part ces derniers camilla
personnes qui comprend ce que les filles
trouvent à cyril est content il est très
respecté dans l'équipe je vais me trahir
un petit secret quand ils traînent dans
sa loge avant de nous rejoindre plateau
il nous manque
ouais surtout à valérie benaïm à elle
j'ai attrapé un autre secret pour les
téléspectateurs sachez que nous sommes
en renégociation avec valérye bédard
pour la rentrée au niveau de la radio et
de la télévision
bon allez on était en est et oui merci
jean découvert sur euros vous êtes là
franchement c'est pas sympa le vendeur
de roses mais je ne devrais pas parler
comme ça de mon patron mais bon je vous
rassure cyril 1
tout le monde ne vous appelle pas comme
ça ça me dérange pas on peut regarder
oui bertrand aussi méfiez-vous du puceau
maléfique il a l'air gentil comme ça
mais c'est une teigne
mais c'est horrible parce que lui c'est
vraiment méchant mais y'a pas que vous
n'y a pas que vous habille les méchants
que tout le monde saute ben oui bien sûr
il en est issu est donc mais même quand
il n'est pas là table regardez le
pendant kenora débattez sur le bachelor
il était très convaincu c'est pas
péjoratif son manque de passer à la télé
les meubles monde passe à la télé mais
il ya une production derrière créé non
mais j'en étais sûr que c'était le pire
but comprendre l'attend deux heures
avant droit
les attentes 6 heures dans ces cas là on
n'est pas pour la violence mais rosicky
méritent un peu que vous vous occupiez
de lui pendant sa rubrique oui
les autres amputé de la bande de gamins
attendaient alors certaines espèces
d'animaux tape aussi beaucoup non mais
je n'achète pas des images s'était
arrêtée avec vous m'avez pas taper mais
vous tellement premier vous provoquez
alors vous tapez ces gens qui vous
provoque c'est moche ça bouge de
répondre par la violence
ben je fais bertron ce n'est pas que ma
fiancée c'est aussi un homme qui de plus
en plus souvent autour de la table et ça
ça le met en joie a vraiment on va faire
un petit jeu je vous montre trois
chroniqueurs pendant le générique
devinez qui est le dernier arrivé est le
plus heureux
quand
aujourd'hui
quant à mes quand vous voulez vous êtes
content comme ça vous restez là voilà
c'est formidable parce que bertrand il
faut ça c'est un jeune chien fou il y
avait un chien fou qui va même trop vite
pour ses voisins
attention tout de suite le moment de
solitude de la semaine
à voir
c'était jean michel von wyss s à
traumatiser c'est ça et ça va trouver
pour lui le groupe va trop vite ça
hésite entre autres va trop vite pour
jean michel maire c'est un side sa vague
de poutès aujourd'hui dans les moments
de solitude ya aussi cet animateur
qu'ici de faire sérieux de faire un
teasing et qui a perdu toute crédibilité
à cause d'un simple stylo regardez bien
en bas c'est le julien courbet dire à
tous dans touche pas à mon poste parce
que c'est plutôt tout péter
ces quelques rayons de thierry moreau
est d'ailleurs gina combien de race mais
vous savez bien de voir mardi gbagbo
tizi l'euro dérape
alors pourquoi tu es dans les moments
pénibles vous le savez touche pas à mon
poste c'est parfois des blagues qui
n'aurait jamais dû voir le jour
face à ces grandes catastrophes deux
attitudes sont possibles soit vous
fermez les yeux et vous vous persuadé
qu'elles n'ont jamais existé
ça voulait regarder en face et vous
faites votre devoir de mémoire
donc ça ne plus jamais ça ne se
reproduise je demanderais de ne pas
applaudir
dévié avant le championnat espagnol le
barça reçoivent ils affrontent de cyril
gely les fûts d'évoluer c'est la bonne
mais malgré tout toujours ue
est ce que tu vois que je peux la sortir
si ali et là moi je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est le maire il va l'envoyer dans le
mur il le sait très bien où il aime bien
mais là c'est important de se rappeler
ces grands désastres pour éviter des
plus grands un comme ce jour où syrie
nous parler de fatou la compagne de
gilles verdez rappelez vous fin tout est
magnifique d'ailleurs je voudrais pas
prêt je vous dis vous avez jamais une
croix la meuf de gilles verdez un avion
arrive au pas cru
et surtout étonnant c'est qu'ils soient
dans l'avion avec la tel qu'il le fasse
j'avais il fallait faire je lui avais
dit le vieux pont à la sortie jean
michel était mérité le problème avec
shell c'est que quand les gens ne rient
pas ne dis pas que ça va des mauvaises
et il se dit juste que les gens sont
trop cons pour l'avoir comprise
donc il revient dessus regardez l'homme
qui ne lâche jamais la faire
bien que ça l'a violée devant bon mais
ça voulait dire qu'il fait d'être
annoncée par m
d'accord
alors la jordanie
suivi du web
jean michel a mis une minute 30 aqua-gym
rds qui ne voulait pas se moquer lui il
a soufflé tout le monde et c'est ça mais
il a quand même un choeur jean michel
voulait il voulait pas qu'ils se vexe
donc logiquement trois minutes après
quand le direct a recommencé et qu'on
parle de the beast voilà ce qu il est
agile et quant à christophe beaugrand
l'atout humour de l'émission c'est comme
s'il faisait que gilles verdez l'atout
sensualité d'une soirée goldbach
deux époques tous les textes sont
mécontents mais ce que j'aime
vas y vas là non c'est pas ça parce que
je connais bien mon jean michel godet
parker quand il brode et dit n'importe
quoi y rajoute des voix là à chaque fin
de phrase et quand ils assument pas une
vad il pousse des sourcils sans raison
que c'est ça renvoyer la scène harry
gilles verdez l'atout sensualité d'une
soirée gala
la nation par nassim passé là il a
survolé la question qu'on pourrait se
poser mais pourquoi il assume titre
pourquoi il a su me rappelle que quand
tu es méchant rappelle très bien tu sais
quand tu es méchant très méchant à moi
que je vous propose d'en revenir cinq
minutes en arrière et nous voilà tous
jeunesse
il a lors de mes cartouches jo buzz et
c'est ça que je rigolais comparer ce que
je le voyais l'été plaisir et l'autre à
côté qui veut sortir une totale au
louvre à la touche jeunesse non pas ça
en tout cas c'était pour assurer un
gilles jean michel d'arrêt contre toi
c'est encore lui souffre parce qu'il
doit dire jean michel items beaucoup il
est plus sympa avec toi et même
admiratif il ya quelques jours street
avait demandé un poème sur les femmes
est ce que tu veux connaître la réaction
de jean-michel juste après run entier
regarde et lui david
et francis pot ou bien les joueurs
fourniret france et sombre dans une
cellule avec le verbe cette plaine
c'était pas sa semaine à gerland mais
j'ai une tant de haine ça cache
tellement d'amour villardry jamais il
est un peu qu'on la voit souvent des
gens me demandent pourquoi je montre
surtout ce côté là de la table des
chroniqueurs si j'essaie de protéger les
autres
eh bien pas du tout c'est juste que de
ce côté là enfin de ce côté-là ça
discute ça dit beaucoup de conneries
alors que de l'autre côté
bah il se passe ça pendant les pubs
badou ce côté là sont papote
mais bon heureusement de l'autre côté
ils sont très prolifiques et même si je
comprends pas tout parce que parfois tu
sens qu'ils veulent aborder des sujets
intelligent mais ils sont pas équipés
pour aujourd'hui dans les conversations
de l'impossible thierry et jean michel
parle de la conquête spatiale
aux états unis où ça sent bon sous
kennedy oh ça sent bon ça
exempt sur la navette spatiale les trucs
qui isole la truck on a encore
l'atmosphère les briques dont celles
utilisées dans les matériaux pour isoler
les besoins blige et mis au point et ton
cul
ça c'est lui qui sonne exactement ya
quand même la joie avec columbus a
exposé on pas voilà ikeda les briques à
la crise était passé c'était fuite
non il n'avait cette maj papa de sa
kalex nouveau décollage c'est qu'il
rentre en atmosphère explosive fixée
marais l'exposer à l'atterrissage
c'est un put de certains des mois sinon
médias génériques et de cause on peut
aimer d'amour qui a jamais eu
d'explosion sar n'a pas on arrête pour
tour mais n'ont jamais de la vie
il dit qu'on a perdu une navette
spatiale en route mais on n'en veut pas
taxer les briques qui sont votées sont
des cadors la pêche et continue que
cette maison je m'en fous basic m ménard
kesraoui ah oui aujourd'hui allez on y
va
bonjour je m'appelle geneviève bouclé de
faire le pont du 1er mai celui du 8 mai
donc je voulais juste savoir ça va les
grosses feignasses